le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
social travailler la terre et vivre de
ces cultures n'est pas toujours évident
surtout lorsque l'on se lance dans
l'agriculture biologique ou raisonn pour
soutenir ses cultivateurs engagés le
département organise des marchés pays
tous les 2è samedi du mois à Saint-Denis
parmi les producteurs Benoît Morel il
cultive des fruits des légumes et des
épices bio à
[Musique]
Saint-Philippe voilà ici c'estager de
d'agrumes citrons les oranges tout ça et
là c'est les cacaos c'est au milieu de
ces 8 hectares de plantation que Benoît
Morel passe ses journées agriculteur
depuis 30 ans il a repris les terres et
le travail de son père en fait ici avant
il y avait que la Anan savoir que mon
papa il était le premier producteur
d'ananas de la Réunion et en fait je
suis pas né dans les chou moi je suis né
dans les champs d'ananas c'est lui qui
m'a transmis Laam de la terre Laam de
l'effort et du courage vu que c'est un
métier quand même assez dur et
pénible aujourd'hui Benot n'a gardé que
quelques plans d'ananas et a choisi la
diversification des cultures avec la
collaboration de la pépinière voisine il
sélectionne et développe des variétés
rares parfois oublié en ce moment c'est
la saison des fruits à pain des
pampelemousse et des caramboles en fait
c'est des c'est une variété je pourrais
dire assez récente amélioré en tout cas
donc des caramboles très sucrés très
juteux dans ce petit bout d'Eden on
retrouve aussi des épices locales qui
ont marqué l'enfance du cultivateur
comme le curcuma dans la cour il en
avait toujours à la maison et dès qu'on
avait une blessure dès qu'on avait un
problème de santé c'était le premier
remède et ça ça m'a manqué beaucoup et
je me suis mis petit à petit et voilà
c'est devenu une de mes cultures
principales tous ces produits sont
cultivés avec passion et surtout avec
respect Benoît est l'un des premiers à
s'être lancé dans l'agriculture bio il y
a 15 ans si j'ai pris cette voie là
c'est c'est déjà pour ma santé moi-même
pour la santé de ma famille et celle des
autres parce que je pense que je suis
aussi responsable pour la santé des
autres produire et proposer des des
produits sains quoi c'est devenu pas un
travail pour moi c'est devenu presque de
dire que c'est possibleologique à la
Réunion pour transmettre son message et
ses produits Benoît se rend sur les
marchés et depuis un an l'un de ces
rendez-vous incontournables c'est le
marché pays organisé par le département
tous les deè samedi du mois cet
événement réunit les producteurs du bio
et de l'agriculture raisonnée c'est une
bonne initiativeement de de voir que les
pouvoirs public les institutions
s'intéressent et nous permet justement
de de faire ce genre de manifestation
c'est important il y a pas suffisamment
de production en bio
par rapport à la demande tu tout dans
les légumes et les fruits et tout ça et
et moi ben j'ai envie me faire connaître
aussi donc c'est pas V que su dans ma
région mais elle est aussi un peu
ailleurs l'agriculteur du Sud est prête
à se lever aux aurores pour participer
au marché pays qui a lieu le lendemain à
Saint-Denis 6h du matin à l'espace
redley dans le bas de la rivière Benoît
finit d'installer son stand c'est un
marché que
éciable l'entourage c'est très convivial
c'est dans un cadre quand même assz
intéressant un emplacement agréable mais
surtout un contact privilégié avec le
client par raortchin il faut savoirchin
il y a un peu tout le monde il y a des
bazardiers il y a des fors il y a il y a
aussi des producteurs mais beaucoup
moins les producteurs et ici c'est
vraiment les producteurs et là c'est la
vente ben du producteur consommateur et
c'est ce que on recherche nous en tout
cas pour le bio on recherche de plus en
plus justement des clients direct pour
qu'il a pas de trop d'intermédiè on un
sac il n faut goûter leur leurs produits
aussi puis voilà quoi j'aime bien
beaucoup cette cet échange ça me fait
rappeler il y a longtemps ce sont des
produits vrais frais c'est vraiment
super ces échanges directs sont aussi
l'occasion de combattre l'idée reçu du
bio trop cher je trouve qu'il y a pas de
très grande différence par rapport au
produits que j'achète habituellement
peut-être un écart de 50 centimes ou
même pas tout juste 50 centimes ou 1 €
pas plus fruits de saison fleurs
produits transformés sur ce marché
agriculteur comme consommateur s'y
retrouvent et espèrent voir cette
initiative se développer il sera
tellement plus important que de faire
venir des choses d'illeurs qui coûtent
beaucoup plus cher alors que nous a tout
à la Réunion pour pouvoir vivre pour
pouvoir développer le
[Musique]
P 2015 le département a organisé 16
marchés pays cette année la collectivité
espère étendre son dispositif créole il
aime bien le le produit frais il aime
bien savoir ce qu'il y a dans son
assiette il aime le le contact et donc
là c'est l'occasion de mettre en
relation le consomme acteur réunionné le
producteur réunionné sur des produits de
qualité parfois produit longtemps
parfois produits nouveaux pour le bien
manger et cette année nous choisissons
vre site le colosse à saint-endré va
accueillir le marché des producteurs
Villelle à Saint-Paul à Saint-Pierre il
y en aura également l'idée c'est
aujourd'hui de pouvoir élargir cette
rencontre entre les producteurs des
régions et les consommateurs dans toutes
les les les régions de lîle c'est le but
que nous voulons atteindre cette
[Musique]
année les marché pays ont pour objectif
de faire découvrir le savoir-faire local
et les produits agricoles de qualité
issus de l'agriculture biologique ou
raisonnée il privilégie le contact
direct entre producteurs et
consommateurs les marchés pays ont lieu
tous les deè samedi du moin à l'espace
redley Saint-Denis pour plus de
renseignements sur ce dispositif vous
pouvez consulter le site du département
au
www.cg974.fr